Hello everyone.
This was pleasure.
I introduce Dr. Lawrence Krauss.
Dr Crosses the foundation professor of the school of Earth and space exploration
at Arizona State University.
He has made significant contributions in cosmology where he was one of the first
physicists to suggest the existence of dark energy,
a substance which may be responsible for 63 sorry,
68.3% of all the total energy in the observable universe.
Dr Krauss is also a tireless advocate for public understanding of science.
He served on the Science Policy Committee for Barack Obama's 2008 presidential
campaign,
contributed articles to the Atlantic,
The New Yorker and Newsweek and written several New York Times bestselling books
on science including his previous book,
the well noted and well regarded universe from nothing.
My first exposure to Dr crosses were came with one of his early books,
the physics of Star Trek,
which I found enthralling for.
It's thorough and altogether serious.
Look at the physics,
plausible and otherwise of one of my favorite series.
It was a brief aside,
Dr Krauss.
I feel like there was a a missed opportunity.
You wrote a followup called beyond star trek and I feel it should have been
named the physics of Star Trek two,
the wrath of crowds.
You taking that out of my,
I put that in my appendix.
Oh,
you did.
Now,
uh,
today Dr Krauss is here to talk about his latest book,
documenting our current understanding of nature,
the history of one of humanities,
greatest scientific achievements,
the standard model of particle physics and its implications for our existence
and what promises to be the greatest story ever told so far.
Join me in giving a warm welcome to Dr [inaudible].
[inaudible].
Thanks.
Well,
it's a pleasure to be here and
see all of you and I,
I'm understand it's lunchtime,
so I shouldn't go over time.
So I'll make a shorter version than normal because I know you have really
important work to do.
So,
um,
in any case,
uh,
the,
the quote that I had here along with the music,
um,
comes from,
uh,
a book that actually a friend friend of mine who is a filmmaker named Werner
Herzog,
recommended to me.
And,
um,
and,
uh,
and he,
you know,
you've met,
he's seen his most recent,
well not most recent,
really big second most recent movie.
Lo and behold,
which is about the Internet,
which is nice when there's another one that just came out,
um,
which is a fiction called salt and fire that I'm also in as a,
as a villain,
but,
uh,
it's a weirder movie.
But anyway,
this,
um,
the move,
this book,
which is called the peregrine,
is about a peregrine.
And,
um,
but it is a wonderful naturalist book if you ever want to read it.
But the quote is what's particular important,
which is the hardest thing of all to see is what is really there.
And that's really the,
the thrust of,
of,
uh,
of the content of my book,
which is that the,
the world we live in is an illusion.
And,
uh,
it's an,
been amazing story for particle physics and,
and,
oh,
look at that.
Okay.
Is there a reason that went off auto power,
off engaged power,
auto power off was engaged.
So waiting for projectors to start.
Good.
Very impressed with the technology.
Um,
the,
uh,
so anyway,
the standard model of particle physics and in fact Parco physics in general has
been about trying to understand the,
uh,
the fundamental structure of matter and energy.
And it is really an amazing story of how different the universe is,
that fundamental skills in the skill we see.
And one of the real implications.
And then one of the reasons the subtitle of the book is called why are we here,
is that the universe that we exist in is an accident in a world defined way,
which I will,
we'll,
I'll talk about until until the,
uh,
until the projector gets,
gets to there.
I'll get,
I'll be,
oh,
that,
let me just get to the slide I want to do.
So when we get,
when the projector actually turns on,
which is certainly not now,
um,
oh,
the light just came on.
That's good.
Uh,
we can get to the image I want to show,
which is of a,
of a window in the wintertime with ice crystals on it.
I was actually just in Phoenix where I teach and I show,
I gave a lecture on this and I had to explain to people those were ice crystals.
But,
uh,
here we go.
Um,
and so these are beautiful,
but what I want you to do is think for a second of what it would be like if you
lived on one of them.
Uh,
so I'd say this one.
Okay.
If you evolved on,
on,
and we can still use that word in the u s um,
uh,
if you evolved on that crystal,
what would,
what would happen while the physicists,
I don't know where it is in that one anyway.
It's,
let's say with this one.
Oh No,
there it is.
Um,
the physicists working in this world would say,
well,
okay,
I can work out the forces.
The forces along the spine of the crystal are very different than the forces
perpendicular.
So they'd come up with laws of physics,
which would explain and predict how things moved,
and they'd be one set of forces in this direction and will forces in the other
direction.
And that would seem natural.
There'd be theologians who'd say,
well,
explain why God ordained that direction to be the proper direction for life.
And there'd be,
and there'd be wars fought over whether that was the right direction or that was
the right direction to pray to.
And um,
uh,
all of that would have significance,
which of course is completely illusory,
that it is just an accident and crystal can point in any given direction.
And uh,
but it wouldn't seem that way if you lived on that crystal.
And that's essentially the world we live in.
All of the facets of the world that looked like make it look like the universe
is designed for our existence,
our pure accidents in a fundamental way,
which I'll try and describe.
And,
uh,
and we,
of course the world looks like it's designed for us,
but at a fundamental level,
it's actually antithetical to our existence.
As I'll describe to you now,
the story is long and winding.
And obviously I said I want to give an abridged version so you can get back to
work.
But,
um,
so I want,
I'll start fairly late into this.
Uh,
but the story actually begins 2000 years ago with Plato and then works work
through Maxwell and Einstein talking about the major revolutions that have
changed our pers perspective of our place in the universe.
And one of the things that describes pretty well the progress of science
certainly in physics in any case,
is when we know made,
made progress when two things that seem very different on the surface are seem
to be different reflections of the same thing.
And then we know we've made progress and that pretty well characterized as
almost all the progress in physics over the ages from,
for example,
in recent times the recognition that electricity and magnetism,
which seems so different are really exactly the same thing.
And one person's electricity is another person's magnetism.
That led to the realization that space and time,
which seemed different are really the same thing and what one person sees a
space and other personal measure as time.
We live in a four dimensional university,
not a three dimensional universe.
And those kind of developments of progressively told us that the university we
see is kind of my opening because we perceive these three dimensional slices of
a four dimensional universe,
which is why it seems so not intuitive to us that the universe is four
dimensional.
And when I'm running with respect to you,
I'm seeing a different three dimensional slice of a four dimensional universe,
which is why things seem strange and relativity does what it does since.
And I talk about those things at great length in the book.
So though up after that point we had,
we developed a theory of electromagnetism and a theory of,
of gravity and all seemed well until we got to a later stage.
And I want to begin the later stage with this guy who all of,
you know,
I assume it's Richard Fineman and uh,
who was probably what,
what was one of the greatest physicists of the second half of the 20th century.
And uh,
what he won the Nobel prize for him with others was the recognition that of
course,
at the fundamental level,
the world is quantum mechanical.
And if we want to have a theory of electromagnetism,
we need to put in a quarter of the quantum mechanics.
And the theory they develop called Quantum electrodynamics is a theory that
merges electromagnetism and quantum mechanics.
And he presented a way of,
of thinking about this,
to understand the electric force between two charges,
which had been understood by Faraday and Maxwell in a slightly different way.
A way we,
we talk a by five and diagrams as we call them,
but it's particularly interesting.
So this is an electron and it repels another electron and it does.
So
by the exchange of a particle,
a Photon,
the quantum of the electromagnetic field of electromagnetic waves come and
particles and photons are the individual Quanta.
Now,
what Fiman used in developing this is a key aspect of quantum mechanics,
which is central to quantum mechanics,
which is really the same thing that's used in Washington and corporate America,
which are now the same thing.
If,
if you can't see it,
anything goes,
okay,
that's basically it.
And we'll learn more about that with investigations over the next.
I certainly hope,
but uh,
but so the idea is that this electron emits this particle,
this photon of light.
But that's impossible.
It's not allowed.
The electronic just sitting there cannot admit it.
Admit a particle of light because where did the energy come from?
If the photon carries energy,
where did the energy come from?
The electronics still there.
If it's an isolated electron,
it can't emit a photon cause that doesn't conserve energy,
but that's okay.
That's allowed by the Heisenberg uncertainty principle,
which is responsible for that Washington rule I gave you the Heisenberg
uncertainty principle says if I measure a system for a short time,
then I can't know it's energy.
Exactly.
There's some uncertainty in the energy.
So if I admit this photon and it violates energy conservation,
that's allowed in,
in,
in quantum mechanics,
as long as the photon disappears in such a short time that I can't measure it,
it's just exactly like embezzlement.
Okay.
I'm,
I'm sure Google does this every day is some level because if you get the money
and as long as you put it back before anyone notices,
it's free.
You can do whatever you want with it.
Right?
And that's that.
You know,
there's a lot of trading that goes into,
in that regard.
So it's exactly the same.
So the photon can take,
it can violate energy conservation here,
as long as it disappears before you can measure it,
you're fine.
And so the photon is exchange and it produces that repulsion.
Now the key point is the photon has zero mass.
It's massless and that's essential to the,
to make electromagnetism along range force.
An Electron here repels an electron and Alpha Centaury okay.
Or anywhere in another galaxy.
And the reason is because the photon is massless.
It can carry an arbitrarily small amount of energy and if it can carry an
arbitrarily small amount of energy that it can exist for an arbitrarily long
time before it has to disappear without violating the Heisenberg uncertainty
principle.
And if it can exist for an arbitrary long time,
it can travel from here to Alpha centaury before it's absorbed.
So the fact that electromagnetism is a long range force is uniquely,
uh,
related to the fact that the photon is massless in this picture.
Okay.
And this photon because you can't see it.
It's called the virtual photon cause it doesn't really exist.
It just it,
you can't ever measure it.
If you look forward,
it's not there.
Okay.
And Ah,
great.
And so this picture,
this is a complete picture of the quantum theory of electromagnetism.
You absorb an emit these virtual photons that can do anything they want as long
as you can't see them.
And this theory is the best theory and science.
It's the best area in any area of science.
So you can,
based on this theory,
you can make predictions and compare them with observations to 14 decimal
places,
which you can't do in any other areas of science where fundamental predictions
compared to observations.
So this is as good as it gets in science.
And in the 1940s when this was developed,
this was great.
We now have a complete theory called quantum electrodynamics,
which,
which explains and predicts perfectly every measurement you can make an Adams
and other things where electric fields are.
So that's great.
Okay.
And now,
and that look great for nature,
but then nature intervened.
Okay.
Nature v intervened with by the fact that the neutron is radioactive.
Now this should disturb you.
Okay?
Because,
uh,
I remember I first learned about it when I was in high school from a guy named
Tommy gold who was a wonderful astronomer.
But,
but,
uh,
you should disturb you because most of the particles in your body are neutrons,
neutrons,
and protons,
makeup atomic nuclei.
And for heavy nuclei,
I certainly there an average more neutrons in there,
our protons.
So the number one dominant particle in your body is a neutron.
Okay?
If I take a neutron here and hold it up,
it will decay in 10 minutes.
Okay?
And you will notice maybe to your chagrin that you've been here for more than 10
minutes and they're still here.
You maybe pray praying for your neutrons to decay,
but,
but they're not.
And why is that an accident of our existence?
So how does new,
what's neutron decay?
While a neutron decays into three particles,
the proton,
that's just a fancier of writing electron,
a proton electron in a Neutrino,
another particle.
The key point,
however,
is that the neutron and Proton way,
almost exactly the same amount,
the difference between these two masses is,
is one part in a thousand.
And so the neutron is barely enough energy to decay.
K if it,
if it's mass was less than the sum of these three masses,
it couldn't decay.
Again,
it would violate energy conservation.
So it's just barely more than the mass of these three particles,
which is why it lasts a long because 10 minutes is a hell of a long time in
particle physics units.
Okay.
I mean,
so it's,
so it seems like an eternity.
So this is a very long lived particle,
but short lived by our standards.
So how come you're still here,
which you may be asking yourself?
Um,
uh,
so the,
it's an accident.
Okay.
What happens when I drop?
Put a new neutron in the nucleus?
Well,
it falls the nucleus and it gets bound.
What does it mean to be bound?
Well,
some of you know,
but otherwise it means that you,
it takes energy to get out.
You lose energy when you get bound.
And so the new tread falls,
the nucleus loses energy but equals MC squared.
So the neutron gets lighter and when the neutrons gets in a nucleus,
it's no longer has its mass is too small to decay into these particles.
So the neutrons are only stable in new glide by that accident.
That the fact that the new Trump proton mass difference is so small that when it
falls into a nucleus,
it no longer has enough energy to,
to a decay and that's why you're here.
That's why they're heavy elements.
If it weren't for that carbon,
nitrogen,
oxygen and all the things that,
that uh,
on which our lives are based would not exist just because of that fortuitous
fact that these particles have almost the same mess.
Okay.
That's interesting.
But more interesting for physicists was,
well this was a little disconcerting because suddenly this implied there was a
new force in nature.
The neutron was discovered in 1932.
Okay.
Suddenly a new force had to because electromagnetism can't cause this decay and
gravity can't cause us to case.
So there had to be some new force in nature that would cause that to gay.
And of course the question is what kind of forces says is it and how we can,
can we understand it?
The first person to write down a theory for that,
any kind of theory was one of my favorite physicist from the 20th century,
Enrico Fermi,
who was the last particle slash nuclear physicist who was equally good at,
at,
at theory and experiment.
The two fields have become sufficiently complicated that you can't do both now.
Okay.
He was the last one who was able to do both really well.
He was very,
uh,
he also historically in the Manhattan project was the one who was assigned the
task of building the first nuclear reactor,
the first sustained chain reaction.
And so he built it,
they built it in the University of Chicago,
um,
underneath the football field,
which I've always viewed as an inspired choice because if anything went wrong,
you just killed football players and there's no loss.
And,
and um,
so fair me,
uh,
built that successfully.
But he also wrote down this first model this and he submitted it to the journal
Nature and got rejected,
which hardens many of us who submit to nature and get rejected.
Um,
and uh,
but he didn't take it well and he,
uh,
in fact,
he said,
I'm not going to do theory.
Now I'm going to just go do experiments,
which was good for him.
It turned out because the next experiment he did won him the Nobel Prize in
physics.
So worked for him.
But uh,
but as his theory was built upon a by others,
now the really important thing,
there are many important aspects of science that I want to try and emphasize and
I try and emphasize in the book because they have relevance.
Well beyond the esoteric physics,
I'm talking about relevance as I'll describe in some sense to the quagmire where
I find ourselves living in right now.
But the one thing that's really important about science is that it's like
Hollywood and maybe like Google actually probably in that regard,
if it works,
copy it.
Okay.
And keep copying it until it doesn't work anymore.
It's like Halloween,
56 or whatever it's going to is as long as you can sell tickets,
keep propping it.
And so if we have a theory that works,
copy it.
So here's the best theory in nature.
So the idea was if you have a new,
if you have a new forest,
let's make it look like this for us.
So we could draw a picture.
If [inaudible] argument,
it looks the same sort of a neutron to of proteins made of quarks,
but that's a little look added.
Complication doesn't really matter.
And then an electron neutrino come out.
And if this works by the exchange of particle,
then why not?
Imagine this force works by the exchange of a particle,
but this force is very different than this force.
This forks works across the universe.
This force,
the weak force operates only on the scale of nuclei.
That's why we don't see it on human scales.
It's only works for on the scale of nuclear.
So it's very short range.
This is very long range.
So weak,
this is strong.
How can you relate those two things?
Well,
if you make this particle massive,
then what happens if this is very,
very massive,
then it always carried then emitting it always produces a lot of energy because
equals MC squared.
So if it's massive,
you can't help but have a lot of energy produced here and that means you violate
energy conservation by huge amount,
which means the particle has to disappear very quickly by the Heisenberg
uncertainty principle because otherwise that huge amount of energy and be
noticed.
So if you emit a particle that's very,
very massive,
it can travel only a very short time and therefore only a very short distance
before it has to disappear.
I like the masters case.
So you want a short range force,
just exchange of massive particle Longreach ports,
a mass as particle,
everything works fine,
but it doesn't because this theory gives the best predictions in nature.
This theory gives nonsense because when you do the mathematics,
you get infinities.
Physicists don't like infinities computer scientists don't like infinities.
Mathematicians love infinities but so,
but we don't.
So,
so the,
the idea is how to get around them.
And this was a fascinating and severe problem is so severe that actually in the
1960s,
when it was kind of first recognized,
many physicists were willing to give up the pretty picture.
They said maybe this unification of relativity and quantum mechanics just
doesn't work on the scale of nuclei.
And it was kind of amazing how easily they were willing to give up this picture.
And one of the things about the book is as,
which is one of the reasons is the greatest story.
It wasn't easy in particularly,
there are lots of red herrings and dead ends and physicists are people,
and that means they're pigheaded and prejudice and biased.
And they often want to go in a direction even when that direction is futile.
Okay.
But the great thing about science is it drags the physicists are the scientists
kicking and screaming in the right direction.
So the individual scientists may be prejudice,
but,
uh,
eventually because of nature,
they're forced in the right direction.
And this case,
these people,
you know,
and especially actually it was interesting in Berkeley,
was the main place where people want to give this up.
And they created a kind of Zen version of physics,
which is appropriate for Berkeley in the 60s.
And it was the sound of one particle clapping basically.
Um,
but it was actually,
it was the basis of string theory got generated there as a way,
an alternative to this picture.
And it failed miserably there too.
But,
but uh,
that's a different book.
Uh,
the point is that these people were looking at the problem and you want to shake
them because in fact,
they had,
the answer was the answer was right there for people if they hadn't been looking
in the wrong direction.
With hindsight is so much easier to see things to see that the answer was right
there.
And the answer came from very different area of physics superconductivity.
So 1911 cameras [inaudible] discovered a Dutch physicists discovered that if he
did,
if he called mercury down to four degrees above absolute zero,
then the resistance went to zero.
Didn't just it come small,
it went to zero.
And that means if I have a mercury wire and I hook it up to a battery and I
started current going and then I cooled to four degrees,
I take away the battery,
then the current continues to flow and it doesn't just flow for an hour or a
day.
It flows forever.
It never ever stops cause resistance is priced precisely zero.
It seems like it shouldn't be possible,
but it is.
It's a remarkable phenomena that he named superconductivity and it's so weird
that it took maybe 50 years to be able to have a theory of this and it has to
with a rather complicated interactions of electrons in materials,
which is nice.
Okay,
so what's this got to do with what I just discussed?
Well nowadays we have high temperature superconductors so we can do need
experiments and high school physics classes cause we can put a superconductor
now in dry ice and there's some materials that becomes superconducting at those
temperatures.
And then we can play with them in high school classes.
And for example,
if you have a superconductor and dry ice and you put a magnet above it,
the magnet will levitate.
Why?
Because it turns out magnetic fields cannot pierce the superconductor.
They die off the surfaces superconductors,
so to electric fields.
But that means the magnetic field lines basically get repelled by the
superconductor,
and that's enough to levitate the the magnet.
It's a fun little game to play in class.
Okay?
Again,
what's this got to do with anything?
Well,
now I want you to imagine that you live in this super conductor
and now you,
I asked you what are the laws of physics not superconductor?
Well,
for you,
if you live in that superconductor,
electromagnetism is a short range force because electric fields and magnetic
fields,
when they answer the superconductor die off exponentially fast.
It turns out.
So if you have a quantum theory,
if you develop quantum mechanics and that superconductor,
you'll describe electromagnetism is a short range force,
and that will mean that the particle that's exchanged is massive.
And indeed in a superconductor,
photons are massive.
They have mass.
They have their master's out here.
They traveled the speed of light and a superconductor.
They're massive.
They travel much slower.
It's just the way it is.
Now,
again,
this should start bells ringing in your head,
but it didn't for the physicist at the time until finally,
someone began to think about,
well,
what if,
what if we live in a cosmic superconductor?
And what if it's like,
like swimming in water?
Okay,
you swim in water,
you feel you're really fast.
And maybe Google has a pool here.
Probably does.
I don't know.
And um,
and but what if you fill it up with molasses?
Oops,
sorry.
What if you,
what if you fill it up with molasses instead of water?
Well,
then you won't want to go swimming first of all,
but,
but if you did go swimming,
you'd swim a lot slower.
It'd be a lot harder.
You'd feel a lot more massive.
So what if we live in a cosmic superconductor and everywhere through space,
I can't resist this everywhere through space.
There's an invisible field,
um,
uh,
permeating all of space and some particles interact with that field and get
resistance and appear as if they're massive and other particles don't.
What if that were the case?
Well then you could draw these pictures.
He's finding dogs.
This is the one I showed you before,
but turns sideways.
And these are the ones for the,
for the weak force,
the one that has a,
produces that electron neutrino in terms of the three particles involved.
But that doesn't matter.
But now what if these particles are massless just like the Photon,
but they interact with this invisible background field that's everywhere and
they act like they're massive in our superconducting world.
And that means that the force they mediate looks like it's short range.
Well,
that would explain how it can be short.
But the neat thing is if they're massless,
then the mathematics of,
of the calculations evolved by the exchange of these massless particles is the
same as that for a photon.
And in fact,
instead of producing infinities it producers correct results.
Moreover,
in fact,
the mathematics is identical.
So not only do these forces appear similar,
in fact they could be the same force.
And nowadays the picture is that these two forces,
which are so different in the world in which we live,
each of which is responsible for our existence,
the electric electromagnetic interactions,
responsible for all the interactions in the biology of your body.
The weak force is actually responsible for the processes that power of the Sun
as well as the existence of heavy nuclei.
And both of them are essential for existence.
But
although they're very different,
they're really the same at a fundamental level.
And at a fundamental level,
they wouldn't look at all like the forces we see in the world in which we live.
This increase,
we were dragged to this picture unwillingly as I say,
and and for a long time,
a lot of people went in other directions.
And it's amazing to think that we were willing to picture a universe that is so
distinct from the university in which we live so uninhabitable if you wish.
So foreign and so alien.
It's one of the wonders,
one of the great aspects of science and art and music and literature,
is it forces us to view our own perspective of our place in the cosmos
differently in a way that may not be the way we wanted.
So it's an amazing intellectual triumph to propose that.
And it apparently works.
But at this point it's kind of religious,
right?
It just think of what I just said.
Imagine there's an invisible blackground field everywhere throughout nature that
that,
uh,
determines why you exist.
Okay.
It sounds a lot like things you would have heard the Bible or star wars or
something like that.
So,
and it wouldn't be,
it would be just an extraordinary claim without evidence,
which is you,
which is religion and it isn't though.
Cause it's physics.
And what does that mean?
That means we have,
if it's there,
we have to find it.
So if this invisible background fields,
it's weird,
ridiculous picture is true and it is a ridiculous picture.
It's one we should be highly skeptical of.
If it's true,
we better find it.
How do you find it?
Cosmic sadomasochism we spank the vacuum.
You spank it hard?
What do I mean?
Well,
all fields in quantum physics,
all fields are related to particles.
So if I dump enough energy at a single point in space,
and let's call this field the Higgs field,
if I dump enough energy and a single point in space,
maybe I'll kick out real particles associate with that Higgs field or column
Higgs particles.
How can you do that?
Will you build the most complicated machines humans have ever built?
In this case,
the large Hadron collider in Geneva,
Switzerland,
which is a particle accelerator.
It's located in Geneva,
and in fact,
if you go to the airport,
and I'm Google probably has an off officers there.
If you go there and you'll see the lake and then the little water spout there,
but underneath the farmland right outside the airport,
which is beautiful pastoral farmland,
a hundred meters below the surface is a tunnel that's 26 kilometers around.
And what we do is we accelerate protons at 99.999999,
nine,
8% the speed of light in one direction,
and then protons at 99.99999,
nine,
8% the speed of light in the other direction.
And we try and collide them in a certain points,
three different points in the data.
In this circle,
they will run thousands of times every second.
Here's the French Swiss border,
by the way.
So they crossed the border without passports and all that,
thousands of times each second,
which Trump would want to change,
no doubt,
but,
but uh,
we end,
this machine was built to be able to see if we could kick particles out of empty
space and kick kicks and producing six particles.
Do this ridiculous picture actually worked.
Now in this country,
we have an uh,
sort of,
uh,
an acronystic day we celebrate called July 4th,
which doesn't mean anything to anyone else,
but now it has a cosmic significance.
Cause on July 4th,
2012,
we reported 50 events
produced in the large Hadron collider that looked like Higgs is that walked like
Higgs.
Is that cracked?
Like Higgs is and we thought we're Higgs is okay.
And in the intro,
any five years now,
almost five years,
all of the experiments of fine tuned those results and they have exactly the
properties that were predicted of the Higgs particle.
Exactly.
This is an amazing triumph because it means that this ridiculous picture we,
which,
which we are pushed to is real.
It means we really live inside of a cosmic superconductor.
And it means that we were driven not just to propose that picture,
but to build this remarkably complex machine to do it.
And to me this is humanity at its best.
This,
their willingness to go where nature takes us first of all,
independent of whether it's or whether we want to go,
but then to amass the resources to look at,
to build this machine just to determine why we're here.
And,
and of course one of the benefits of science,
which many people,
Harold and is responsible for all your jobs is technology,
which is great,
but you know,
it's a little bit unfortunate too because that means when,
when you have science and people always say to me,
well what good is it?
What,
what does it,
does it make a better toaster?
Doesn't make a faster computer.
What is it?
And if it doesn't do those things,
it's,
it looks like it has no utility.
But of course we don't ask those things about a Mozart Concerto or a Picasso
painting or,
or,
or a Shakespeare play or you pick your favorite whenever an Eric Clapton Song,
whatever.
And Science is exactly the same.
The real virtue of science is exactly what I said earlier,
not the technology it produces,
which is nice,
but its cultural significance,
which is the fact that it forces us to cheat,
to get out of my myopic picture of ourselves,
just like art,
music and literature.
To see ourselves in a broader sense,
to get a better perspective of our place in the cosmos in this case,
to be willing to build these amazing machines.
I call the large Hadron Collider,
that Gothic Cathedral of the 21st century.
The gothic cathedrals were beautiful things built over centuries by thousands of
artisans using the highest technology at the time.
They didn't know how to make these ceilings so they wouldn't fall in for a long
time.
All working together.
Well,
the large Hadron collider was built by 10,000 phd physicists and and then many
more engineers in fact from over a hundred different countries.
Speaking does is different languages,
many different religions all working together for a single purpose,
which is what science can do.
It can unify people from all cultures.
It's what Google does here.
Look at all the people from different cultures working for a common purpose.
That's what science does.
That's humanity at its best.
And the machines are unbelievably interesting.
Complicated.
This is one of the smaller detect,
well one of the larger detectors,
sorry,
it's not the machine,
it's just a detector in the machine.
The smaller detector have here is this called a compact mew on solar annoyed,
which is not so compact.
It has this same amount of iron as the Eiffel Tower for example.
It's hard to see it.
I have a better picture of it cause I'm there.
Um,
but it's really you when you go there and if you do go to and when the machine's
down,
you can ever know and then go down and just amazing to see the scale of
everything compared to the scale we exist that,
but the machine,
you can't,
it's,
you can't have almost enough hyperbole.
I have a whole chapter in the book about,
in,
for example,
every second of the large Hadron Collider,
enough data is generated to more than 1,001 terabyte hard drives.
Okay.
Which is relevant to all of you.
And it's every second.
We have to process that much information,
a thousand,
a thousand terabytes of information in that experiment.
And that means as you can imagine,
that you have to filter that information and,
and it's incredibly complicated but interesting from a computer science point of
view.
But it more than just that for example,
the,
the tunnel that it's in,
it has to be evacuated that 26 kilometer long tunnel has to be evacuated.
So it's vacuum is sparser than the vacuum outside the international space
station.
Every aspect of the machine is remarkable.
And the fact that we're willing to do this,
to just address this question of why we're here,
it seems to me to be,
uh,
the,
the bravery of the people who devoted their lives to building this and the
people who have devoted their lives to coming up with a theory is,
is,
is one thing.
But the thing part of my book that maybe that part of the title that's the best
is the so far apart,
the greatest story ever told so far because the story gets better.
Unlike that other story called the greatest story ever told,
which is written down by Iron Age peasants who didn't know the earth orbiting
the sun is still the same,
just as boring and untrue.
This one changes and it doesn't change US cause cause we like it.
It changes because every time we open a new window on the universe,
we're surprised and we're forced out of our comfort zone.
And,
and I,
you know,
so I think of this,
I happen to like impressionist art and,
and I like art in general,
but why we like I'm an impression to start is that it's beautiful from a
distance,
but when you get close up it's really crappy.
Okay.
And that's,
that's science because great.
We've developed this incredible model called the standard model that explains
every experiment we can ever have ever been able to perform in particle physics.
But then the minute you make that discovery,
there are always new questions.
Why did this Higgs field form in the early universe,
why did it freeze in place?
Why did freeze the way it did?
So that we,
it resulting in our existence,
all of these new questions,
and the point is this story will get better because the next January people,
as long as we continue to ask questions and have the courage to be able to look
out and try and find the answers,
the story's going to get better.
And a story will get better and more interesting and produce a universe that may
seem more strange.
And,
and that story that we've developed and that we've now validated,
as I say,
is a story which,
which is terrifying at the same time as it's awesome.
And the consequences are ones we may or may not.
Like.
One of the first consequences,
as they said,
is that our existence is a cosmic accident in a real sense.
Just the same as that,
that uh,
on that window sill,
I mean those people who live there,
okay,
that that direction is very special and it means a lot to that civilization just
as all of the facets of our universe that looked like it make the universe is
designed for us to therefore make it seem special,
are accidents.
The underlying universe is not only not designed for us,
but as I said,
to antithetical to our existence.
Because if theW and z particles and all of the particles in nature where
massless as they are at a fundamental level,
if it weren't for this field frozen in the universe,
then we wouldn't exist because no,
no bound objects could exist.
There wouldn't be any people,
any stars and the galaxies,
anything that we could see and these,
these fas physicists on this window,
on this crystal might eventually discover that,
you know what?
This is just an accident of our existence.
Said crystals in different directions,
conform it.
There's nothing special about that direction.
And maybe they'll just cover that at like in the morning one day,
but then at six in the morning,
the sun will rise in Seattle that you may not.
There's this thing called Sun and and and it,
and,
and melt all these crystals.
Okay.
Then there's symmetry restored it to be no preferred direction.
But the unfortunate thing is these people wouldn't exist anymore.
And the interesting thing,
and maybe terrifying thing is that if you actually look at the Higgs field and
look at the value it has,
then it's just teetering on the edge of melting.
Okay.
It just,
the Higgs particle happens,
have a mass.
It's very close to the mass where if you look at the model,
the field could be unstable and melt.
And if that were to happen in our universe,
then then of course everything we see disappears.
Okay.
Now don't be,
don't be worried.
There's still time to buy books and stuff.
But,
but more than that,
if you actually do the calculations,
it's probably stable.
But even if it's unstable,
if you work out the time frame over which it might decay,
it's not a million years.
Not Billionaires are not a trillion years,
not even a trillion,
trillion year.
So it's,
it's,
this is a long process if it's going to end,
but if it does the universal revert to this symmetric beautiful form,
but it,
but,
but then there'll be no life.
So even this beautiful university,
it looks like it's designed for us will disappear and,
and will,
there's certainly be no life like we see.
And that I want to just end with,
with some notes about how this picture relates to this sort of history of
science in a,
in a,
in a real way.
Because
we are,
we're evolutionarily evolved to look for design.
We always look for designs.
We were on eyes pick it up very well.
And many of you are our talented looking for design,
which is probably why you're where you're here.
Okay.
But,
but that design may not really be there.
And we have to second guess ourselves.
One of the things that Fiman really said,
which is quite important is the easiest person to fool is yourself because you
like something or you want it to be that case.
And we all want design.
We,
you know,
you can think of human things that are developed like Christmas ornaments.
They're clearly designed,
but of course those aren't Christmas ornaments.
Those are snowflakes that you just give me a polar molecule and laws of
chemistry and physics and our produce,
these beautiful things without any design.
But you might say,
well what about human structures like the Google plex or,
or,
or this building or are my favorite is Buckminster fuller domes.
Cause when I was growing up,
every hippie had one and lived in them and didn't eat things in them.
And uh,
and,
but there are evidence of,
of an very interesting intellect,
Buckminster fuller,
who was a really interesting guy.
Crazy but interesting.
Well,
just take sought bar.
Take Soda.
If you take,
you'll find out in the sorta part of our molecules called carbon 60 we now call
Buckminster fuller marine,
which are beautiful geodesic domes.
And there's nothing less designed that soot.
So we have to be careful when we look for design in nature.
The first real example of this was from one,
of course,
the greatest scientists of all time.
Charles Darwin and,
and if you haven't read the origin of the species,
the last paragraph of it is really beautiful.
One of the most beautiful lines in any science book,
any everywhere.
There's grand jury in this view of life with its several powers having been
originally breathed into a few forms or into one and that whilst this planet has
gone cycling on according to the fixed law of gravity from so simple,
a beginning,
endless forms,
most beautiful and most wonderful have been and are being evolved now.
This was a beautiful discussion of how the complexity and diversity of life on
earth,
which appears to be designed could arise naturally from a simple beginnings by
natural selection and evolution.
And that design like the fact that bees could find flowers was not designed,
it was a,
if they couldn't see the colors of flowers,
they wouldn't reproduce.
And it could be understood from much more simple principles and you could get
incredible complexity from simplicity.
This same paragraph could be used to describe the university we physicists are
talking about from so simple beginnings with the forces of nature may have been
unified in a simple way.
We as the universe evolve produce through structures like all the stars and
galaxies and people and all of the structures we see today by a simple process.
And,
and that universe is no more designed for us.
Then life is that we're carrying on that Darwinian process,
which is,
which for many people is disturbing because they want the universe to be
designed for them.
It's comforting,
okay?
But the universe doesn't give a damn what we want.
And we have to learn that,
you know,
the universities make terrifying,
but it's also incredibly awesome.
Not a university isn't designed for us,
can actually be more interesting.
It can be one in which our lives are more precious.
Cause the only purpose we make [inaudible] only personally have as a purpose we
make.
But you know,
scientists,
as I said,
individual scientists are products of their time.
So in a letter,
Joseph Hooker,
he said it's mere rubbish.
Thinking at present of the origin of life.
One might as well think of the origin of matter and in [inaudible] 63 it was
rubbish to think of the origin of the matter,
but now I get paid to do it.
Okay.
Because the story has gotten better,
the story has gotten better because we continue to push the boundaries in our
thinking,
but more equally important in our looking out,
we continue to be willing to build experiments and look out and be willing to
change our perspective even if it takes us in a direction we don't want to go
and,
and I want to end by in some sense by saying I'm worried about this future in
the,
at the present,
in the current budget,
for example,
proposed by the president,
the entire field,
I talked about particle physics.
The support for that has being reduced by 20% $900 million,
but more importantly the agency that supports it,
which is the Department of Energy which most people don't realize is the chief
funder of all physical science in our country.
Not just energy research,
but all physical science in our country is being caught by 20%.
At the same time.
The National Endowment for the humanities is being caught completely.
The National Endowment for the arts cut completely.
The national,
um,
the corporation for public broadcasting cut completely the institute of Museums
and libraries,
which supports museums and libraries around the country cut completely.
You add all that up and you get 1.8 $2 billion savings in our budget.
Okay.
In the same budget for host a $2 billion line item,
which is the first installment of a,
of a wall with Mexico.
Okay,
so you got this wall that's going to protect us from hordes that are unknown at
the same time killing all of the sport for culture and largely this port for
science and,
and,
and the way to picture that was actually to me express best by Robert Wilson,
who was the first director of the Fermi national accelerator laboratory.
The first big,
no,
not the first big,
but the biggest accelerator in the world until February until the large Hadron
collider was built.
And in 1960s he was called before Congress and asked the question,
well,
an aid in the defense of the nation and here was his response.
No Sir,
I don't believe so.
It only has to do with the respect with which you regard one another.
DV,
the dignity of men,
our love of culture.
It has to do with are we good painters,
good sculptors,
great poets.
I mean all the things we really venerated in our country and our patriotic
about.
It has nothing to do directly with defending our country except to make it worth
defending.
And that is a beautiful statement and and is particularly poignant today because
we risk getting rid of everything that makes this funky worth defending in an
effort to apparently defend it.
What wakes America great if at anything does is the contributions that will make
and the people in it will make to the legacy,
the future of our children,
the perspectives of the world are understanding the new ideas we develop.
That's why people,
as you can see from here,
that's why people come here from around the world because there's some benefit
because the contributions we make for the future,
if we get rid of all that infrastructure just to defend ourselves,
the greatest story ever told will not continue being great,
at least not here.
And,
and so I want to end with two quotes.
One from the beginning of my book,
which is a famous quote from Virgil.
These are the tiers of things and the stuff of our mortality cuts to the heart.
It's from the beginning.
I needed,
I remember learning that in Latin because I grew up in Canada and I was
educated.
But,
uh,
the next line,
which is not so well known,
uh,
but I pointed out at the end of the book is release your fear.
And that's the point.
Only if we release our fear of the unknown of others of a universe that may or
may not be the university we like,
only if we're willing to go into the unknown.
Will this greatest story continued to get better?
And we may live in a universe that apparently has no purpose,
apparently isn't designed for us and apparently maybe miserable in the future.
But that's okay because we are fortunate,
more fortunate to have a evolve this consciousness that allows us to ask these
questions for the short time we're here.
And so we should enjoy our brief moment in the sun.
Thank you.
[inaudible]
uh,
so you made an analogy with the arts.
I think the,
the,
the obvious rebuttal there is that it's easy for people,
anybody to see the value in the arts to be,
you know,
it's,
it's sort of directly titillating the senses.
You don't have to be,
you don't have to go on through a music school to appreciate the buck.
I don't have to be a scientist to look at the Hubble space telescope picture and
see,
it's amazing.
I mean,
I,
the point is that,
you know what,
if you do go to music school,
you'll appreciate Bach a lot more,
but you can appreciate boxes by listening to it.
But the wonders of the universe are easily appreciated by everyone,
especially children.
We beat it out of them.
Yeah.
The Higgs,
the Higgs Particle for instance.
That's a lot of explaining to get to that.
Yeah,
that's why I wrote a book.
but the point is,
you know,
not everyone has to understand the Higgs particle,
but it's there for those want to get there.
Just like it's there for those who want to pick up a guitar and learn how to
play it.
But you don't have to understand the Higgs park of what you knew.
What really need is you can,
anyone can understand that the basic world around them,
if we provide them the opportunity and more interestingly,
and this is really important if we teach science as it's supposed to be taught,
which is not a bunch of facts.
That's why we live in this world of alternative facts because people in school
are taught that,
you know,
almost all subjects or just a bunch of facts.
Science is a process for discovering facts and that's the process that anyone
can learn it and we and we damn well better start teaching it because,
because of Google in particular when I was growing up,
that was the place to get information.
But because of Google,
I can get more information from this,
but I can get also more in misinformation.
And the only way I can tell the difference is science is skeptical inquiry,
reliance on empirical evidence,
testing my ideas,
checking many sources.
And so that's the thing that really is the greatest legacy of science is that
process.
And that's the thing we need most,
not just for the enjoyment of looking out at a Hubble space telescope picture
and getting a kick out of it.
I mean,
everyone has had Aha experiences when I used to work at science museums when I
was young.
You're like orgasmic.
We call them Aha experience.
When you suddenly see something a new way and it happens to everyone and there's
lots of science that we can do.
But more importantly,
those tools are necessary if you want to,
if we want to have an informed electorate who can actually distinguish policies
that are related to empirical reality from policies that aren't.
So it's,
there's actually a,
an imperative as well as a joy.
But I agree with you that that the,
at least the perception among the public is that you can enjoy music,
art literature with a much lower impedance barriers.
We call it in physics much lower wall.
It seems take a little bit more.
But I do think that's a product of our school systems.
Yeah,
it's definitely worth it.
Trying to,
yeah,
but I mean,
I think if we teach kids,
not answers,
but questions,
how to ask questions,
we're all Hawaii or to want to discover the answers and it's okay to not,
I mean,
the information is irrelevant in the school.
Most of what you learn high schools or you lose sure.
Reading,
writing,
arithmetic.
But beyond that,
most of what you learned as an adult,
it's going to be way beyond what you learned in school.
Most of the physics I do as a scientist,
I learned after my phd.
And so those tools are important,
but the joy is there for everyone at different levels.
And I think we,
what we don't do well enough is tell people,
you know,
it's just amazing how you can enjoy music without being a musician and joy.
You don't have to.
But the common sense view is you cannot enjoy science unless you're a technical
person.
And we have to get over that in my opinion.
I had a small question about your own discussion of Berkeley earlier.
I was wondering what you think about scientists,
um,
kind of believing in the theories they're working on,
uh,
without proof to,
to drive it forward.
They have to,
it's,
I mean,
it,
you know,
science isn't based on faith,
but if you're going to spend 20 years,
your life working on something,
you've got to have a,
I wouldn't call it a belief,
but you'd have to say to yourself that you,
there's some thing tells you it's strongly likely to be true and you can be
completely wrong.
But the great thing that differentiates that from religion,
let's say,
is that if you're a scientist in the end,
if it's shown to be wrong,
you throw it out like yesterday's newspaper.
Even if you spent 20 years your life on it.
That's the difference.
But certainly you cannot work the,
the,
the builders,
the large hadron collider or the developers,
the standard model couldn't have done what they'd done or even the string
theorist.
Now the people that my colleagues are,
do I have students of mine who are well known string theorists,
you know,
so I just wouldn't want my daughter to marry one but,
but um,
but uh,
uh,
but they,
they're,
they have a good reason for doing what they're doing.
And the hope is that the,
somehow the theory will make contact with reality,
but if it won't,
you can be darn sure.
And it's already happening.
In some sense.
You saw when the Higgs was discovered that lots of string theorist went and
jumped ship because suddenly there was new particle physics to look at.
So yeah,
that we all have to have that kind of faith.
But the differences that the faith is not in science is eminently shakable.
The wonderful thing is that it is not iron clad.
And,
and that's supposed to be the great virtue of faith is that you don't give it
up.
But in science,
the great virtue of faith is that it has no,
no utility beyond its utility.
Okay.
Good.
I guess I'll,
thank you.
[inaudible].